turquía no ha esperado nada en responder
a esta declaración de reconocer el
genocidio armenio por parte de byd en
tan solo segundos después de la
publicación de tl este comunicado de la
casa blanca del ministro de asuntos
exteriores turco mesut sólo ha hecho un
comunicado explicando que esta medida
por parte de esas unidades una unidad
populista que sólo busca dañar las
relaciones que ahora mismo ya están
atadas de turquía y los estados unidos
de hecho turquía se queja sobre todo a
su argumento en este caso se queja es
que eeuu ha tomado esa decisión en un
momento en que las relaciones entre
turquía y eeuu son muy malas y en ti
está cataloga en este movimiento de
oportunistas sin embargo durante toda su
historia de casi 100 años turquía nunca
ha reconocido este genocidio armenio que
sí reconoce en la mayoría de expertos
internacionales sobre el tema turquía
asegura que en este caso lo que pasó
fueron las matanzas durante la primera
guerra mundial entre turcos y armenios
sin embargo es evidente que el consenso
internacional es que un dicho ejercicio
si ocurrió de hecho el término genocidio
fue instigado a través de una persona
que obtuvo familiares que parecieron en
estas matanzas de 1915 por lo tanto
turquía ahora mismo se encuentra en un
momento complicado en sus al programa
internacional probablemente de los 30
países que ahora mismo reconozcan al
genoa civil después de este
reconocimiento de yongbyón lo hagan a
otros países en el mundo y por lo tanto
en llevar a problemas geopolíticos y
diplomáticos para turquía